you can cry you better
[Music]
our asses are gonna go see patty Jenkins
talk about Wonder Woman yohko spice type
diet - [ __ ] [ __ ] ate a
piece of spice man nectar Instagram
story right now as I'm recording this on
my iPhone I am regretting giving away my
two GoPros I received out of the
kindness of my heart now that I decided
to do mini vlogs for patreon I have a
GoPro oh you have a GoPro yeah how
should have asked about that [ __ ] run
the lights on run the line there it is
people YouTube space you choose the
spice that's where the algorithm comes
from that's where that algorithm is and
the ads are not I do vlogs for patreon
[ __ ] the tuatara
yeah she look happy as always da where
we sat here we held it's got the job
person awesome Jonah does other side
thing for the movie
[Music]
I didn't bought it I bought this ball my
own money
wake up to twenty-five dollars believe
that [ __ ] good YouTube space people the
best part about all you Tea Party is the
free food that's just a side salad like
it's a big Muriel deciding probably
after the next half-hour
why would I take this all in on my own
I'd rather just record it and move on so
I'm talking about crap Lady Bird on
burrito reacted Oh
high-quality content right here look who
I bumped into the black nerd comedy rods
over us over a real free Jerry I kinda
remembered me the black nerd reject I
tagged him in my videos yeah that way
I'll get more views how to hide Nanni's
I don't know you guys think you art
designs are cool
it's helicopter if everyone else then
please come inside [ __ ] see or post up
somewhere paddy and Jimmy are going to
be down here and you're going to get
some exclusive footage so enjoy the rest
of you night and you will see you that
girl smiled at me earlier I thought she
was bored with me now I realize you're
just being polite we toasting the whole
thing
[Music]
foreign people are also important
and hearted people she got the sexy
stripper pole here and no idea my
getting more than just the patty Jenkins
shattered a so I found out they're going
to be showing us exclusive footage yeah
well I can see some more of one
perfectly but we can't record at all
during and ever again but I think we're
going to try it and then get our channel
shut down by posting it all on the good
life the real next Kim same is that
we're good for sex tape stuff start
superstar to her reality show all going
now right here's the stay tuned
everybody keeps out okay so it was a
long ass QA you're probably going to
find a really good quality version of it
somewhere else but in the meantime I'm
gonna play some of the QA that really
stood out to me particularly this one
woman who cried who I almost cried just
as she cried it's like he was moved said
and then you couldn't when I couldn't
capture though was I looked around I was
like there's a lot of other people
crying it was a weird moment to be like
I kind of wish I was a woman right now
video so I can be okay to just cry
forever sure I wish everyone instead of
four women in the world well you know
get the sex change operation expiring
about sex change operation
[Music]
all right so we're leaving right now
I was pretty awesome that was a really
awesome QA boy the exclusive footage
they showed every I bumped into a few
people that didn't put on camera because
I didn't really care I wasn't thinking
about it at the time honestly but above
the like Jason in Man Mark Ellis i'ma
talk a black nerd about it for a while
and everyone really loves the movie and
my brother to who can have a much more
difficult time with movies than I do he
even really enjoyed the movie a lot and
then when we saw the footage and then
seen it was it's nice to know that
there's a good DC eu3 coming out and
then the exclusive footage John and I we
look at each other like holy [ __ ] this
subdued footage was [ __ ] yeah like the
clips they show were like this is some
good by two very different clips they
made the discards like we're going to
show you a little bit of footage to give
you a sense for some of the different
elements this movie has yeah and they
did a good job they made me [ __ ] excited
yeah I was I was I I already felt like
this would be a good movie but now but
now that with the QA and then meeting a
bunch of people in person more than just
a Twitter response of initial reaction
was like okay yeah this is never going
to be a good DC here boom I'm glad I
bought my tickets a while ago for this
ever I asked everybody I spoke to if
they saw it and if they saw it they said
yes and what they thought everybody said
I they're like good - [ __ ] great yeah
depending on who they were you will all
be posts I mean I probably like a little
kind of mini a blog once a week or
something like that but it takes for the
patron community there this one might go
up on YouTube I don't know maybe just a
little shameless plug to go to the
bakery on that's what I do
the patreon comer to the patreon
commercial now grifter we got you that's
our we got you is you want more
and pledged $1 to see more